[Music]  it's the ultimate dragon ball z  experience  relive the story of goku and other z  fighters through four sagas in this  action rpg  [Music]  protect the earth from an invasion by  vegeta in napa  frieza take a stand against the evil  emperor  cell battle the androids in a fight to  the death  majin buu an epic showdown with the most  fearsome foe  along with the main story you can  explore the vast world of dragon ball z  hey why not help out the locals or  collect ingredients for delicious meals  you could always train to acquire new  skills too  there are lots of things to keep you  busy the boss battle episodes a new  power awakens parts 1 and 2  is also included dragon ball z kakarot  plus a new power  awaken set punches its way onto nintendo  switch september 24th